hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're gonna talk about iodine iodine
facts there's very interesting mineral
it's a trace mineral trace minerals are
minerals that are needed in smaller
amounts okay
so 30% of the body iodine is stored in
the thyroid gland okay
the thyroid gland concentrates iodine
and it uses iodine to make its hormones
so when you see t4 and t3 3 & 4
represent the number of iodine molecules
in that hormone t4 is an inactive form
of thyroid and then t3 is the active
form of thyroid and it's converted
through the liver and the kidney okay so
70% a greater amount of iodine is in the
salivary glands it's in the breasts then
the ovaries the stomach lining the eyes
the cerebral spinal fluid it's in the
substantia [ __ ] that's in your a part
of your brain so it's not just
necessarily in the thyroid so iodine is
important in many different things in
preventing fibrocystic breasts I mean
this is like the easiest thing to get
rid of it you give someone iodine I mean
that stuff just goes right away assists
on the ovaries
so the female reproductive organs need
iodine iodine tends to lower estrogen in
the body it actually converts estradiol
to s3 all the good estrogen so that's
pretty cool so if there's an estrogen
dominant situation you would want to
take sea kelp or iodine so with the
stomach lining the eyes even in the eyes
if you're deficient iodine you can
actually get little tumors in the eye
cerebral spinal fluid parkinson's in the
substantia [ __ ] if you're deficient in
iodine parkinson's so so there's a lot
of different other health problems that
are related to iodine but the body
doesn't necessarily store iodine it
basically 90% of it goes through your
kidneys and you get rid of it so you
have to constantly get it in the diet
which is not easy because unless you're
doing seek help or or seafood or you're
buying food that is from a shoreline by
the ocean you're not going to get a lot
of iodine because of the soils are so
depleted so it also is made to make
hormones we talked about that convert
estrogen rids heavy metals so when
people take Ida or seek help and they
get a reaction instantly they think that
it's an allergy but not necessarily all
the time the reaction could be the
detoxification of heavy metals or
chemicals like bromine chloride and
fluoride so because iodine is a
detoxifier you can have a little bit of
a reaction where it might be even worse
inning the skin or the cystic acne or
whatever but only for one week and then
those go away what I would do if you had
a reaction
I would I would cut down the dosage or
actually I wouldn't take it all wait for
that to clear up and then take small
amounts gradually over time because if
you stop it it's like it's starting to
work and then you could have actually
gotten some really good results from it
instead you stop taking it and you're
not going to get the benefit so just
realize that go slow with iodine or seek
help if you're going to take that but it
does get rid of heavy metals and it can
create a reaction iodine is really good
for cystic acne though too so a lot of
people are trying to get rid of that
also it helps insulin resistance which
is very interesting we have a lot of
videos on that iodine is necessary in
the improvement of insulin resistance
because it makes glucose more sensitive
to the body also it it helps cold feet
now if you have cold feet that can be a
thyroid issue and you would want to take
seek help to fix that so I I put a link
down below of a very high quality seek
help if you wanted to find one but I
wanted to give you some information
about iodine and it's not just about the
thyroid it's about the entire body so
thanks for watching